this is the craziest thing that's ever
happened to me bachelor star Peter Weber
is 100% okay after suffering a face
injury while getting into a golf cart in
Costa Rica in an exclusive statement to
ET the show's host Chris Harrison
revealed Peter suffered a freak accident
while abroad I'm very far from perfect
although Chris says Peter has a cut on
his head and did get stitches
he assured fans the new bachelor is
quote still the dashing handsome pilot
we've all dreamed of and says production
is already back underway I have no idea
what's going on in the outside world
I just ready to immerse myself in this
journey and hopefully come out with the
fiance at the end how still flying high
Weber was confirmed as the season 24
bachelor in September after placing a
third and becoming the windmill star of
Hannah Brown's season of The
Bachelorette I'm really happy for him I
mean I had real feelings for him season
24 of The Bachelor premieres January
2020 on ABC
[Music]
[Applause]